By now we know how Sexual reproduction in
plants takes place. This is what
we have learned. The flower which is the
reproductive organ of the plant,
bears the male and the female parts.
The male part - the stamen contains the male
gamete while the female part -
the pistil has the female gamete. Fusion of
the two gives rise to an embryo.
Now let us get to know how exactly the process
occurs. Let us learn about it in
detai!
But before that, tell me one thing - do all
flowers always possess both the floral
parts together? Some of them do.
What do we call the types of flowers which
possess both the male and female
floral parts together? Flowers which contain
both stamen and pistil together
are called Bisexual flowers. Can you name
a few examples of such types? Rose,
China rose are a few in this category.
what about other flowers then? Don’t they
contain both the male and female
floral parts together? some flowers such as
those of Gourd and Pumpkin
possess either stamen, or pistil. That is
the reason why such flowers are called
Unisexual Flowers.
Now getting back to the process, the first
step is that of Pollination. It is
theprocessby which pollen grains are transferred
to the female reproductive
organs of a plant.
In other words, pollen from the Anther are
transferred to the stigma.
does this process occur only between two flowers
of the same type? Yes, that
is correct. Pollination occurs between the
flowers belonging to the same type.
And does that mean pollination occurs only
between two flowers borne on the
same plant?
that question leads us to the types of Pollination.
The type in which pollination occurs between
flowers borne on the same plant
is called as Self Pollination. So what will
the next type be? The other type of
pollination is called Cross Pollination where
the pollens travel from the anther
to the stigma of a different flower on another
plant.
can you guess how this process of transfer
of pollen grains occurs? For this,
there are several agents which aid the process.
Agents such as wind and water
are the abiotic ones. On the other hand, biotic
pollinators such as bees, bats,
moths and birds also help in the process.
The process of pollination makes sure that
the pollen grain safely lands on the
stigma. But what happens next? Does
this
lead to fertilisation directly? Or are
there any intermediate steps? We will answer
all these questions in the next
video!